how to win at Scrabble with expert
advice from Natalie's LT Scrabble is not
just a simple word game
it requires strategy and an
understanding of mathematics and
probability here are 5 tips to improve
your game tip 1 learn your twos there
are 124 2 letter words aloud in Scrabble
try to learn as many of them as you can
even if they look a bit weird then play
them parallel to your opponents word to
score big points
tip 2 go for the bonus if you play all
seven letters in one turn you get an
extra 50 points how can you improve your
chances of getting a bonus keep good
combinations of one point tiles on your
rack especially those in the word
retains these six letters go with every
letter of the alphabet except for Q and
Y to make a seven letter word
[Music]
tip 3 get your hooks in a hook is a
letter that can be added to the front
for end of a word to make a new one s is
the most obvious but there are many less
obvious ones you can use to surprise
your opponent with a high scoring play
[Music]
airline airline slander Islander [ __ ]
bhaji tip for developed your ana
grabbing muscles practice Ana gramming
whenever you can
cryptic crosswords and puzzles can help
sometimes normal words can be
surprisingly hard to spot a geared
guitars
but
goodbye tip 5
change is good don't be frightened to
exchange some or all of your tiles
rather than playing a word it can be the
best thing to do the high scoring tiles
are not always good from an opening rack
like this there is nothing you can
usefully play exchange 6 tiles and just
keep the letter e now that looks a lot
better follow these tips and you'll find
yourself winning a lot more than you
lose even though it certainly feels
great winning isn't everything don't
forget to have fun
you